the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video hbo has
finally given us an official release
date for house of the dragons very first
season not only that but they also
revealed new official images of some of
the characters during the filming of
different scenes from the first season
as well
now as you all know house of the dragon
will be the first successor show of game
of thrones in this new series we will
see what happened in westeros roughly
170 years before the main events of a
song of ice and fire house of the dragon
will focus on what happened during what
is known as the dance of the dragons
when house targaryen was in a civil war
over the iron throne resulting in their
very own downfall not only would most of
the targaryens die during the dance of
the dragons but so would most of their
dragons as well
the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a targaryen civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
birthright
before the war house targaryen counted
18 dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again we should be in for one
hell of a ride
now let me show you some of the new
images released by hbo in the first new
photo we have king viserys targaryen
himself he will obviously be the head of
house targaryen as well as the king of
westeros during the first season of
house of the dragon now if you aren't
familiar with how this story will unfold
i will lay out some of the basic
information for these characters the
main reason why the targaryens end up
fighting each other over the iron throne
is because of what happens after king
viserys dies
you see during king viserys's reign of
the seven kingdoms he actually named his
daughter rhaenyra targaryen as his heir
for the iron throne he initially did
this because he wasn't able to have a
son with his first wife emma aaron
unfortunately his first wife along with
their son died shortly after she had the
child
now since viserys did not want the iron
throne to go to his brother daemon
targaryen he named his daughter as his
successor instead
now when all of this was happening
viserys was still a young man although
his first wife died he eventually did
get married again to a woman known as
allison hightower who happened to be the
daughter of his hand of the king otto
hightower shortly after viserys marries
alice sent they end up having several
children together including several sons
now in king viserys's eyes this doesn't
affect his line of succession he still
allowed his daughter rhaenyra targaryen
to be his heir for the iron throne
although alison had now given him
several sons well as you can imagine
things don't stay this way after viserys
dies
after he died allison doesn't allow the
message to get to rhaenara who was now
living on dragonstone
instead she gives the crown to her and
viserys's first son aegon targaryen the
second of his name as you can imagine
this started an all-out war over the
iron throne because rhaenyra obviously
believed it was rightfully hers which i
do agree with
that should be more or less how we see
things unfold in the new series now i am
obviously leaving out a lot of things
but if you would like a more detailed
description of what happened i will link
one of my other videos down below that
video goes over everything george r
martin wrote in his novel fire and blood
alright now in this next photo we have
rhaenyra targaryen daughter of king
viserys targaryen and as i just
described she will be his heir for the
iron throne next we have allison
hightower daughter of the hand of the
king serado hightower and wife of king
viserys targaryen she will be one of the
main reasons why rhaenyra doesn't get
the iron throne immediately after her
father died here we have allison's
father serado hightower who i just
mentioned is the hand of the king it
already looks like he is up to no good
in the photo
he's definitely giving me some little
finger vibes with that look on his face
now in this next photo we have daemon
targaryen king viserys targaryen's
brother daemon will without a doubt be
one of the most interesting characters
in house of the dragon he also just so
happens to be george r martin's favorite
member of house targaryen
now although he is rhaenyra targaryen's
uncle we will see them in an incestuous
relationship together but as you all
know this is nothing new for game of
thrones in the next photo we have lord
corliss velaryon and his wife rhaenys
targaryen they will be fighting for the
sight of rhaenyra and daemon lord
corliss velaryon will be one hell of an
ally for rhaenyra and daemon because not
only is he one of the wealthiest men in
the seven kingdoms but he also commands
the largest fleet of ships as well by
the age of 37 corliss was hailed as the
greatest seafarer the seven kingdoms had
ever known he was also said to be as
brilliant as he was restless and
adventurous as he was ambitious
he will eventually go on to become the
hand of the queen for rhaenyra targaryen
now one of the good things about his
wife rhaenys targaryen is the fact that
she is a dragon rider just like rhaenyra
and daemon as you can imagine this will
certainly be of use during the dance of
the dragons as a matter of fact we
should see rhaenys engage in one of the
greatest dragon battles during these
events now in the next photo we have a
young rhaenyra targaryen and a young
alice in hightower they were actually
good friends before king viserys died
but we will see where everyone's motives
lie once that iron throne is up for
grabs they will not remain friends for
very long next we have a character known
as masaria also known as lady misery now
although she will become the unofficial
mistress of whisperers for rhaenyra
targaryen daemon will be sleeping with
her as well
according to some records rhaenyra
actually allows daemon to have this
relationship with her hbo also released
a photo of sir kristin cole who will be
the lord commander of the kingsguard for
alison's son aegon after he takes the
crown and the iron throne from rhinera
and last but certainly not least we have
an official release date for the first
season of house of the dragon episode 1
will release this summer on august the
21st and i for one cannot wait we now
have an official date for when we will
finally see house of the dragon
hopefully the game of thrones fandom
will rise from the ashes like a phoenix
to take back its rightful seat as the
number one show on television as always
make sure you subscribe now if you want
to stay up to date on any and all
information regarding game of thrones
house of the dragon or a song of ice and
fire
as you all know hbo will be releasing
more and more information as we edge
closer and closer to that release date
and i will be making videos about
everything every step of the way i want
to thank everyone for stopping by and
watching this video hopefully i will see
all of you back here for my next one
also don't forget to watch my other
video down below if you want more
information about these events anyways
have a great day everyone i will see you
soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you